- [Subhi] I am Subhi Nahas.
I am a Syrian gay refugee activist.
Before the war, it was not safe at all
for me to walk around.
Al Qaeda come into my hometown,
and they said they will
apply Sharia law and cleanse
the city of all, like, sodomites.
I expected to immigrate, I
did not expect to run away.
I am an advocate for LGBT
and LGBT refugees' rights.
When I went out from my country,
I found that the peace of mind
and the safety that I felt,
I wanted everybody else to feel the same,
and I want them to feel, like, safe.
Syrian LGBT face double discrimination.
You escaped to save your life;
you escaped your family rejection;
and then to find your true self.
It is difficult to really live your life,
but sometimes it's healing.
You start to realize how bad things were,
and how good they will be in the future.
The Castro is a place where you can
be whatever you wanna be.
It may give you this courage
to come out to yourself,
and be who you wanna be,
and the person that you're supposed to be.
I always thought that home is a location,
but home is where your friends
are, where your love is.
If home is not that, then I don't think
I'll find it anywhere else.